today EU Health ministers analyzed draft
regulations concerning medical devices
the council approved the progress report
that the Italian delegation
submitted which we thought was important
now as a step in the process and we hope
that the incoming laian presidency will
be able to build on our contribution and
um conclude work on these two files the
revision of the EU laws on medical
devices would ensure the highest level
of protection for European patients and
healthc Care Professionals conclusions
were adopted on
vaccination member states were invited
to improve National vaccination programs
and increase public
awareness patient safety and quality of
care were also at the top of today's
agenda ministers adopted conclusions to
improve the prevention and control of
healthcare Associated infections and
antimicrobial resistance every year in
the EU approximately 3.2 million
patients are estimated to catch a
healthcare Associated infection of which
20 to 30% could be prevented on medical
Innovation the council reached
conclusions aiming at a faster approval
of new medicines and at more affordable
prices to
patients finally ministers were updated
by the commission on the Ebola
situation